hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live schön dass ihr dabei seid
Privatjets dicke Autos Luxusyachten
killen die Reichen das Klima oder geht's
da mehr um Bashing so oder so was muss
passieren darüber wollen wir heute reden
und dafür haben wir gleich zwei Gäste
die in ihren Ansichten ziemlich weit
voneinander entfernt sind wir haben den
Buchautor und Verleger Julien Backhaus
und wir haben Theo schnaar von der
letzten Generation außerdem dann später
noch den Klimaexperten Felix kreuzig von
der TU Berlin wir sind gespannt auf eure
Kommentare und eure Fragen die könnt ihr
gerne posten oder schickt uns eine mail
ja lass uns starten mit tierisch nahe
von der letzten Generation schönen guten
Abend schönen Abend die letzte
Generation hatte heute Nachmittag einen
Treffen mit Verkehrsminister Wissing was
wollten sie erreichen was hat's gebracht
also dieses Gespräch war denke ich guter
erster Schritt auf dem Weg zu einem
großen Wandel wir haben von Anfang an
gesagt wir sind gesprächsoffen wir sind
an konstruktiven Lösungen und
interessiert und genau das haben wir
heute auch wieder unter Beweis gestellt
das war ein erstes Treffen es wird
weiter oder es wird ein weiteres auf
jeden Fall geben und ja wir bleiben da
also im Gespräch und schauen dass wir
vielleicht Lösungen finden für die
großen Probleme die uns bevorstehen ihre
Gruppe hat heute eine Presseerklärung
veröffentlicht da steht drin das heutige
Gespräch mit dem Verkehrsminister sein
menschlich respektvoll und äußerst
ergiebig gewesen konkrete Ergebnisse gab
es aber nicht also ähm vor dem
Hintergrund dass sie Straßen blockieren
den Verkehr lahmlegen man muss auch
ehrlicherweise sagen viele Menschen
mittlerweile an den Rande ihrer Geduld
bringen ähm kommt Ihnen das dann
vielleicht nicht ein bisschen dünn vor
also ich denke dass der respektvolle
Umgang lernen im Gespräch geherrscht hat
schon mal ein sehr gutes Zeichen ist die
Sprache die Rhetorik die gegenüber uns
als Bewegung benutzt wird die nimmt der
teilweise eine absurde Aggressivität an
gerade von Seiten der Politik wenn wir
da an Vergleiche mit zum Beispiel
Straßen Schlachten zwischen
Nationalsozialisten und Sozialisten
denken und insofern ist eben ein
menschlicher Umgang und respektvoller
Umgang schon auch etwas was
herausstellbar ist und darüber hinaus
betone ich das gerne noch mal wir sind
gesprächsbereit wir sind an
konstruktiven Lösungen interessiert und
das hat sich heute auch wieder gezeigt
dass dieser dass dieser Weg durchaus
eine erst den ja auch gerne gehen wollen
da gibt's direkt eine Frage an die
letzte Generation spricht an sie wie
soll diese Form der Aufmerksamkeit
helfen bisher regt sich die Bevölkerung
nur über die Aktivisten auf der geht
nicht um die Politik der geht um die
Bevölkerung
ja da gehe ich gerne darauf ein vielen
Dank
ich weiß dass diese Protestform viele
Menschen empört was darüber passiert ist
dass wir gewissermaßen eine kreative
Spannung erschaffen wir müssen immer
wieder uns damit auseinandersetzen warum
setzen sich der Menschen auf die Straße
und wenn wir das ehrlich tun dann müssen
wir eben auch ehrlich über die
Klimakrise sprechen und dann kommen wir
an den Punkt dass wir sehen in
Frankreich gibt es gerade über 500
Kommunen wo kein fließend Wasser mehr
aus dem Wasserhahn kommt in Spanien
trocknen die Stauseen aus die Wälder
brennen 60 bis 80% der Ernte fallen
dieses Jahr aus was uns betrifft weil
Spanien ist die gemüsefabrik Europas und
dann kommen wir an den Punkt das gesagt
wird von den klimawissenschaftlerinnen
Essen eigentlich alle Technologien und
Lösungen da der politische Wille fehlt
und dann ist eben die Frage wo wie
kommen wir zu diesem politischen Willen
und dadurch dass wir konstant Druck
machen nicht mehr ignorierbar sind
werden immer mehr Menschen genau diesen
Punkt kommen dass sie sagen okay wir
brauchen diesen politischen Willen wir
müssen selbst Druck ausüben und das
vermitteln unsere Proteste über die
Unterstützung für ihre Bewegung werden
wir später noch sprechen ich würde gern
zu unserer Eingangsfrage zurückkommen
killen die Reichen das Klima und dazu
möchte ich gerne den Autor und Verleger
Julien Backhaus in die Runde holen
ja er ist in Deutschland viel unterwegs
für Termine nutzt er dann auch gerne mal
ein Privatjet er sagt er macht sich
wenig Gedanken um das Klima er glaubt
dass er damit niemanden aktiv einen
Schaden zu
[Musik]
ügen guten Backhaus guten Abend ja es
gibt Menschen die stellen sich die Frage
ob man sich Menschen wie sie noch
leisten kann wie fühlt sich das für Sie
an also ähm ich glaube natürlich gibt es
dieses Bashing jeder sucht irgendwie
entschuldigen wir sind definitiv also
wenn ich dieses dieses wir jetzt mal in
den Mund nehmen soll definitiv nicht die
Schuldigen oder auch nicht die einzigen
die irgendwas falsch machen oder richtig
machen die Bewertung liegt immer im Auge
des Betrachters ich glaube dass
Wohlstand immer auch etwas imitiert das
heißt CO2 oder andere Stoffe und ähm
deswegen ist es ja kein gutes Zeichen
des so viele Menschen auf der Welt sich
eben keinen Strom und etc nicht leisten
können sondern dass sie ja dass das eben
dann doch nur die reicheren Länder
können
Volker schreibt auf Youtube niemand
sollte sich für diesen klimaquatsch
einschränken müssen also es gibt
durchaus Unterstützung für ihre Haltung
am schauen wir uns vielleicht ein paar
Zahlen an die zeigen dass wir natürlich
alle was fürs Klima tun müssen nicht nur
die Reichen nicht nur die breite
Bevölkerung aber einige möglicherweise
dann doch mehr als andere Laura Rosinus
mit den mit der Bahn zur Arbeit fahren
nicht mehr fliegen kein Plastik
verwenden sich einschränken fürs Klima
was bringt das eigentlich im Schnitt
verursacht jede Person in Deutschland
einen Ausstoß von etwa 11,2 Tonnen
co2-äquivalen abhängig vom eigenen
Lebensstil also z.B davon ob man Auto
fährt oder in den Urlaub fliegt Klima
verträglich wäre weniger als ein Zehntel
davon der Haken Privatpersonen sind
nicht allein verantwortlich für die
Emission ein großer Teil davon kommt aus
Energiewirtschaft und Industrie sie
waren 2021 für den Ausstoß von 428
Millionen von CO2-Äquivalenten
verantwortlich
wie hoch unsere eigenen Emissionen sind
hängt auch davon ab wie wohlhabend wir
sind laut climate in aquality Report
waren 2019 die reichsten zehn Prozent
verantwortlich für fast die Hälfte der
Emissionen weltweit ein Beispiel private
Flugverbindung die gibt es auch bei uns
in Deutschland sind vergangenes Jahr
mehr als 58.000 private Maschinen
gestartet oder gelandet das hat mehr als
208.000 Tonnen CO2 verursacht am
häufigsten genutzt die Strecke zwischen
Berlin und Köln die kürzeste Strecke im
Privatjet von einem deutschen Flughafen
aus 22 km Luftlinie
also muss man schon sagen klimatechnisch
ist es natürlich eine verheerende Bilanz
Herr Backhaus wie rechtfertigen sie ist
dass sie für das Klima schädlicher sind
als andere ich glaube nicht dass sie das
rechtfertigen muss also ich habe eine
Möglichkeit gefunden zu reisen sehr
schnell zu reisen sehr bequem zu reisen
so wie es tausende andere auch tun und
nutze diese Möglichkeit sehr gerne
auf Youtube bis sie Milliardäre in einen
sauren Apfel beißen wird die Sonne
explodieren wie kommen Sie darauf klar
wenn sie solche Argumente hören
also ich würde gerne am Anfang noch mal
deutlich machen worum es eigentlich geht
wir reden von CO2-Emissionen und wir
sprechen in dem Zuge davon dass die Erde
sich immer weit erhitzt und das wird
katastrophale Konsequenzen für uns alle
haben das geht in die Richtung das zu
spät Mitte des Jahres jahrhunderts ein
Drittel der gesamten Bevölkerung der
Erde fliegen oder sterben muss einfach
weil es zu heiß ist in den Gebieten wo
sie leben darüber sprechen wir und wir
sprechen auch darüber dass uns vor Ort
die die Flüsse austrocknen und die
Wälder verbrennen es geht also es geht
also wirklich darum dass wir alle gucken
dass wir rauskommen aus fossilen
Energieträgern und dann ist ihm die
Frage wie schaffen wir das wir müssen so
schnell wie möglich CO2 aus und dann
andere Treibhausgase in den Ausstoß
reduzieren und in diesem Zuge müssen wir
eben auch die Frage nach der
Verantwortung stellen welcher wie wer
kann wie viel dazu beitragen dann ist es
in den letzten Jahren in den letzten
Jahren so gewesen die anderen zwei
Drittel unseres Landes also die
Durchschnittsbevölkerung wenn Sie wollen
die haben in den letzten Jahren ihre
Emissionen gesenkt und das reichste
Drittel hat die Emission immer weiter
gesteigert und dementsprechend ist es
eben wichtig auch da die Frage der
Gerechtigkeit zu stellen weil eben auch
hier katastrophalen Auswirkungen zuerst
diejenigen treffen die am wenigsten
dafür können
am sind in dieser Argumente egal
ich glaube viele Argumente davon sind
maßlose übertrieben ich glaube überhaupt
nicht daran und ich habe ein bisschen
was darüber gelesen sicherlich bin ich
kein Wissenschaftler sicherlich hat der
Kollege auch einiges darüber gelesen
wahrscheinlich auch mehr als ich aber
ich sehe bisher nicht dass ein Drittel
der Menschheit sterben wird oder die
Welt untergehen wird etc weil die
Menschen sich immer angepasst haben es
gab natürlich immer Schwankungen die
wird auch weitergeben und es wird auch
eine sehr viel höhere Temperatur geben
ich glaube das ist auch unstrittig und
ich glaube auch dass wir nicht über 1,5
Grad sprechen müssen auch ich glaube der
IPC hat schon bestätigt dass das
irgendwie gar nicht möglich ist und der
Professor der nachher eingeschaltet wird
hat es in einer Video auch schon gesagt
das ist sehr unrealistisch ist auf
diesen Wert zu kommen also selbst wenn
jetzt alle reichen Länder der Welt
komplett aufhören würden zu imitieren
würden wir ja trotzdem eher in Richtung
4 Grad gehen also dementsprechend müssen
wir uns ja wahrscheinlich langsam sehr
viel stärker Gedanken darüber machen wie
wir mit diesem Problem umgehen und nicht
dieser Wunschvorstellung hinterher
hängen dass wir irgendein 1,5 Grad Ziel
erreichen ich möchte hier ganz scharf
reingehen und zwar aus dem ersten Punkt
den ich wirklich ablegen möchte heute
abend mit ihnen eines da dass dieser
katastrophalen Auswirkungen zu
verharmlosen das ist das ist die höchste
Klimawissenschaft die wir haben und das
ist bestätigt von den Vereinten Nationen
und ich denke auf die Vereinten Nationen
können wir uns als Quelle durchaus
einigen das ist einfach das ist eine
Veröffentlichung die das die haben
gesagt ein Drittel der Menschheit wird
sterben der hat gesagt dass 20 also die
die Prognose ist das 20% der der
Landfläche nicht mehr bewohnbar sein
werden weil es dort einfach zu heiß ist
zum leben wir können doch nichts anbauen
und wir können uns da wir können halt
auch nicht mehr leben weil unsere Körper
ist nicht mehr schaffen uns
runterzukühlen in diesen 20% werden
Leben 3,5 Milliarden Menschen zu diesem
Zeitpunkt das ist dann ein Drittel der
Menschheit diese Menschen müssen fliehen
und die fliehen an Orte wo andere
Menschen leben die auch Probleme haben
weil auch da ist weniger Wasser gibt und
weil es dort
dementsprechend auch Nahrungsmittel
knapper werden und die Preise steigen
und diese Mix aus verschiedensten
Katastrophen führt eben dazu dass die
Vereinten Nationen davon sprechen dass
es sich hier um eine zivilisatorische
Bedrohung handelt ich möchte wirklich
dass wir davon wegkommen diese
katastrophalen Auswirkungen zu
verharmlosen das ist das eine und das
andere ist dass wir eben auch ganz klar
die Aussage haben von
Wissenschaftlerinnen die sagen es ist
möglich die Ziele noch zu erreichen wir
sind gerade dabei die hart zu verfehlen
und wir verfehlen die aber hart weil
eben die der politische Wille fehlt weil
die Regierung in dieser Welt nicht in
der Lage sind das Ruder rumzureißen und
das ist eben genau das warum wir in den
Protest gehen weil wir sagen das kann
nicht sein das muss ein starke Regierung
geben es muss starke Regierungen geben
die da halt reingehen und klare Regeln
schaffen wie wir das Sozialgericht eben
schaffen diese katastrophalen auswir
kungen zu verhindern
Herr Backhaus das sind ja
wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse die kann
man ja nicht einfach ignorieren sie
können sie können sagen ich mache das
aber trotzdem so aber ignorieren können
Sie sie doch nicht nein ignorieren kann
man die natürlich nicht und man muss
damit ja arbeiten aber das was der was
der Herr gesagt hatte habe ich anders
gelesen also ich habe gelesen dass
irgendwann mal das politische Ziel von
zwei besser 1,5 Grad festgelegt wurde
dann wurde die Wissenschaft auch dieses
ipvs IPC gefragt was müssen wir dafür
tun um das zu schaffen und dann haben
die so nach dem Motto geantwortet
eigentlich unmöglich aber wenn man es
machen wollte dann müsste man also
wirklich Radikals alles verändern und
CO2 Emissionen auf Null fahren und so
weiter und so fort das wäre
wahrscheinlich so als würden sie jeden
verkehrsfachmann fragen wie könnten wir
die Unfall Toten auf Null bringen dann
würde er ihn wahrscheinlich sagen wenn
alle nur noch 5 km/h fahren würden dann
könnte man das schaffen aber die
Realität ist ja eine andere die Realität
ist Jahr dass wir immer noch sehr viele
Arme und aufstrebende Länder auf der
Welt haben und dir interessieren sich an
scheiß dafür ob irgendjemand hier in
Westeuropa sagte ich möchte hier mein
mein handy akku ein bisschen weniger
laden damit ich drei Kilo weniger CO2 im
Jahr verbrauche sondern die die wollen
ja in erster Linie irgendwas zu essen
haben und wollen in zweiter Linie
wirtschaftlich aufsteigen und das das
tun sie auch und da sind sie auch bei
und dabei verschmutzen sie sehr stark
die Erde natürlich und die die die Klima
Krise wenn wir sie mal so nennen wollen
die entscheidet sich ja nicht hier in
Deutschland sondern die entscheidet sich
ja bei den großen Emittenten und die
werden weiterhin die nächsten Jahre und
Jahrzehnte extrem viel imitieren weil
sie sich es auch gar nicht leisten
können so sparsam zu sein wie wir wir
haben hier eine Art Luxus Diskussion wir
müssen uns ja nicht darüber Gedanken
machen ob wir morgen Essen auf den Tisch
bekommen aber es gibt eben viele
Millionen Milliarden Menschen auf der
Welt die haben ja genau dieses Problem
und die scheren sich nicht um
irgendwelche Klimaziele das heißt wenn
wir mit unseren zwei Prozent hier in
Deutschland irgendwie auf 1,8 kommen
oder vielleicht 1,5 oder selbst wenn wir
es komplett einstellen könnten was nicht
möglich ist über den nächsten Jahren
dann würde das ja trotzdem nichts daran
ändern dass China und dass das Indien
und Pakistan und wie sie alle heißen
trotzdem sehr sehr viel weiter Gas geben
werden ich finde es sehr interessant
dass sie den globalen Süden ansprechen
und dass diese Menschen sich dort nicht
im Klimaziele Scheren in Pakistan ist
ein Drittel der Bevölkerung betroffen
gewesen von der gigantischen Flut die
ohne Klimakatastrophe so nicht
stattgefunden hätte und darüber hinaus
sind sehr sehr viele Länder gerade auf
dem afrikanischen Kontinent auch auf
anderen Kontinenten die bereits jetzt
unter der Klimakrise zu leiden haben
daher schon Hungersnöte und die
herrschen dort auch weil wir sie in
Abhängigkeiten haben es wird zum
Beispiel auch ein globaler
Schuldenschnitt gefordert von
verschiedensten Organisationen auch von
uns ähm eben um den
für den Ländern über auf die Möglichkeit
zu geben nachhaltig oder klimap positiv
sogar zu zu arbeiten aktuell gibt es
Länder die Zahlen 80 Prozent ihres ihres
Bruttoinlandsproduktes an den globalen
Norden und das sind Dinge die wir die
wir aufbrechen müssen die Menschen
scheren sich um Klimaziele weil für
diese Menschen bedeutet das schlichtweg
gerade das Überleben das ist der eine
Punkt der andere Punkt ist dass sie
gesagt haben dass wir dass wir das
irgendwie gar nicht mehr schaffen können
wir müssten viel umstellen ja wir müssen
viel umstellen weil der Weg den wir
gerade gehen da führt uns in die
Zerstörung und das müssen wir auch so
klar ausdrücken und das heißt aber nicht
dass wir einfach alle unsere Handys
jetzt ausmachen und dann viel keinen
Strom mehr verbrauchen sondern wir
sprechen hier eben auch über
Gerechtigkeit und wir sprechen darüber
dass wir einen Landwirtschaft anders
aufstellen dass die Klima positiv ist
dass sie wieder gesünder ist für die
Menschen das heißt weg von ähm von so
einer groß durch industrialisierten
Agrarwirtschaft die auf Pestiziden
z.basiert und es bedeutet eben auch dass
viele Menschen in der Verantwortung die
sie haben was dazu beitragen und da sind
eben Menschen die mehr CO2 ausstoßen
stärker in der Verantwortung alle müssen
ihren Beitrag dazu leisten ja und wenn
wir das und und dafür aber dass wir das
eben alle können und das ist auch ganz
natürlich ist braucht es eben braucht es
eben ja einen starken Rahmen und diesen
starken Rahmen die muss die
Bundesregierung vorgeben dass das für
uns ganz natürlich ist weiß ich nicht
zum Rad zu greifen um halt schnell um
die Ecke zu fahren weil es eben einen
sicheren Radweg gibt und ich nicht um da
um das Leben meines Kindes bangen muss
nur weil halt sämtliche Politik auf dem
Auto ausgelegt ist das ist eine Frage
die eben von der Bundesregierung geklärt
werden müssen
wenn sie die Argumente von Herrn
Backhaus hören stellen sie sich da nicht
vielleicht die Frage ob sie vielleicht
auf dem falschen Trip sind wenn sie
Autofahrerinnen und Autofahrer auf der
Straße blockieren also sitzen ihre
eigentlichen Endgegner vielleicht dann
eher in den Privatjets und die fliegen
dann ihre über ihre Köpfe hinweg werden
sie sich auf der Straße festkleben also
zunächst ist natürlich deutlich
schwieriger ein Privatjet zu blockieren
aber Spaß beiseite ich glaube wir sind
auf einem sehr guten Weg und zwar aus
verschiedenen Gründen einerseits weil
ich selber auf der Straße deutlich mehr
zustroffen mittlerweile erfahren wenn
wir in die Geschichte schauen wie früher
Bewegungen funktioniert haben die genau
diese Protest vom gewählt haben wie wir
dann war es auch da so dass diese
Protestform in sich eine große Ablehnung
erfahren haben aber die
dass das Unrecht dass diese
Protestbewegung und adressiert haben so
groß war dass die Menschen als darüber
ganz klar gesehen haben nicht hier muss
ich etwas ändern und ich glaube da sind
wir auf einem auf einem sehr guten Weg
und ich glaube das ist auch eher
unüblich für Protestbewegungen haben wir
auch die Unterstützung wie z.B vom
UN-Generalsekretär Antonio gut der ganz
klar gesagt hat wir brauchen diese
Störung um die Zerstörung zu stoppen
also wenn ich in den Chat schaue dann
sagt Julia nature auf Youtube sie ich
finde die Aktion der letzten Generation
sehr gut und werde da auch bald
mitmachen es wird Zeit dass endlich mehr
gemacht wird dann schreibt Delta nein 12
auf Youtube die letzte Generation soll
doch eine Partei gründen und sollten Sie
gewählt werden können Sie all Ihre Ideen
durch und umsetzen warum machen sie das
nicht
fällt aus verschiedenen Gründen der
erste Punkt ist Professor Stefan
Rahmsdorf hat letztes Jahr gesagt wir
haben jetzt ungefähr noch so drei Jahre
in denen wir effektiven Klimaschutz auf
den Weg bringen müssen so in letztes
Jahr drei Jahre des entspricht etwa der
Legislaturperiode der Bundesregierung
das heißt die aktuelle Bundesregierung
ist die letzte die das wirklich noch
effektiv machen kann das ist die eine
Antwort die andere Antwort ist dass eben
sozialer Wandel wie wir ihn brauchen
also eine große Transformation wie wir
brauchen in der Geschichte eben häufig
vermittelt worden ist durch
prozessbewegungen eben wie die unsere
nehmen wir zum Beispiel das
Frauenwahlrecht das ist auch auch
Realität geworden weil Menschen ganz
aktiv den Alltag unterbrochen haben da
sind mutige Frauen aufgestanden wir
haben doch ganz andere Sachen gemacht
als wir die haben Fenster eingeschlagen
in Straßenzügen die haben quasi
Briefbomben gebaut und
und ein Briefkästen in die Luft gejagt
und diese Menschen sind damals auch
nicht geliebt worden sondern ganzen
Gegenteil die wohnen abgelehnt auch von
Frauen der damaligen Zeit und haben aber
etwas erstritten was für uns heute einen
Grundrecht ist was für uns
selbstverständlich ist das ist nämlich
das Frauenwahlrecht gibt
es
was halten Sie denn von den Maßnahmen
die die letzte Generation ergreift also
wenn man mal hier schaut ein riesen Fan
scheinen sie ja nicht zu sein
was halten Sie davon
ich finde diese Rhetorik sehr sehr
erstaunlich ein bisschen beängstigend
auch weil es eben so eine Art
Kriegsrhetorik ist und es ist so eine
sehr gewaltorientierte Rhetorik und es
werden auch keine ausgeglichenen
Argumente ich meine ich habe ihn jetzt
gegen argumentieren aber es wird ja eben
nur eine Seite beleuchtet so wie der
Kollege eben sagte gibt's in Asien
natürlich auch Überschwemmungen und
starke Stürme etc hier ändert da an
bangladespanner der hatte glaube ich
über Jahrzehnte und Jahrhunderte ganz
ganz viele Tote zu beklagen eben weil
immer wieder in dieser Schneise so
schlimme
Unwetterkatastrophen passiert sind und
da hat man in den letzten Jahren ja auch
dazu gelernt wo früher 15.000 Menschen
jedes Jahr gestorben sind also im
Durchschnitt eine Statistik sterben da
glaube ich heute noch 12 weil man
einfach gelernt hat wie geht man mit
diesen Naturkatastrophen um und das ist
eben etwas wo ich wo ich das auch so ein
bisschen der letzten Generation schon
vorwerfe dass sie nur diesem
idealistischen Ziel was
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht erreichbar
sein wird und was mittlerweile ja
scheinbar auch die UN zugibt oder
zumindest Vertreter deren dass die sagen
wir können das eigentlich wenn der Trend
weltweit so weitergeht nicht erreichen
dann müssen wir uns doch langsam über
Maßnahmen Gedanken machen und ich meine
es gibt ja viele Länder auf der Welt die
unter dem Meeresspiegel leben wir haben
eine Nachbarn hier mit Holland und die
haben ja gelernt wie es funktioniert und
die können sicherlich dieses Wissen auch
in andere Länder exportieren das heißt
wir können natürlich weiter versuchen
uns jetzt jahrelang die Schuld in die
Schule zu schieben wäre hier denn mehr
dazu beiträgt dass das ähm dass sich das
Klima aufwärmt aber Fakt ist es wird
sich auch Wärme und es wird sich sehr
viel stärker Aufwärmen als diese 1,5
Grad und der Backhaus was könnten Sie
welchen Beitrag könnten sie dazu leisten
ich meine Mittel hätten sie sehr ich
glaube Unternehmer sind vor allem darin
gut Innovationen auf den Weg zu bringen
mutig zu sein riesigen einzugehen also
Menschen wie ich oder andere Kollegen
investieren halt eben mal ihr ganzes
Geld in irgendwelche neuen Projekte
jetzt bin ich natürlich kein Produzent
von irgendwelcher Klimatechnik sondern
wenn jetzt Zeitschriftenverleger aber
ich glaube ein Elon Musk hat in den
letzten zehn Jahren mehr für die Umwelt
getan als die letzte Generation auch
wenn seine Bilanz von einem Elektroauto
heute noch beschissen ist aber das wird
sich ja verbessern dadurch das Geld in
diese Branche hineinfließt und so müssen
wir ja Innovationen betrachten
Innovationen werden immer da gemacht wo
Menschen eine Nachfrage erzeugen und die
gab es am Anfang nicht für Elektroautos
in Deutschland hatte man schon vor 20
Jahren darüber nachgedacht letztendlich
ich meine seit wann gibt es Elektroautos
seit dem an äh seit dem Anfang des 19
Jahrhunderts oder 20 Jahrhundert haben
1900 irgendwas haben die die ersten
Elektroautos erfunden unter anderem die
Frage was was tun sie und haben sie
nicht gerade vielleicht weil gerade weil
sie privilegiert sind eine größere
Verantwort ung in den Klimaschutz zu
investieren und das zu unterstützen also
zum Beispiel Bill Gates sie haben Irland
mask genannt die Spenden Milliarden und
investieren in Klimaschutz das ist ja
auch gut dass sie das machen weil sie
verstehen davon was und sie
interessieren sich dafür ich nicht so
ja vielen Dank ich finde elonas ist ein
sehr merkwürdiges Beispiel weil ihr Mast
nicht sehr viel tut für Klimaschutz also
ich denke da gibt es für verschiedenste
Ansatzpunkte und auch E-Mobilität ist
nicht die Lösung unserer Probleme das
ist genau der Punkt wo die Wissenschaft
eben sagt wir müssen umdenken es reicht
nicht jedes Auto durch ein E-Auto zu
ersetzen sondern wir müssen grundlegend
darüber sprechen wie wir uns bewegen von
A nach B wie wird es möglichst gut
schaffen können und das ist das eine und
also auch wenn er Backhaus immer sagt
dass die UN etwas zugeben das ist das
völlig falsche Wort die un-warnen
Duellen warnen dass die Regierungen
nicht auf dem richtigen Weg sind und die
waren ja schon eine sehr lange Zeit
nämlich länger als ich lebe ich mit 32
Jahre alt und vier Jahre vor meiner
Geburt war der Welt völlig klar diese
katastrophalen Auswirkungen sind
Realität und die werden kommen und
damals hätte die Welt jedes Jahr 2% der
Emission einsparen können aber das
Gegenteil ist der Fall gewesen ist
einfach immer weiter gestiegen und jetzt
sind wir an einem Punkt wo wir sehr
drastisch Emissionen senken müssen da
führt einfach keinen Weg dran vorbei und
da müssen wir auch nicht auf irgendeine
wundertechnologie hoffen die da
vielleicht noch kommt
ist nicht diese diese CO2-Speicherung in
etwa ja das ist alles wichtig und das
klingt interessant aber die ist in
bestimmten Klimamodellen bereits mit
eingerechnet und das ist immer noch
nicht so fähig wie sie wie sie sein
müsste aktuell und da ist eben der Punkt
dass wir sagen okay wir müssen die
Technologie nehmen die wir jetzt haben
und wir haben genug täglich Energie und
wir haben die Konzepte
das zu ändern unserem Planet lebenswert
zu halten und die müssen wir umsetzen
und da spielt eben auch der Punkt mit
rein dass wir sagen okay wir müssen auch
darüber sprechen wer wie viel wie viel
beiträgt und ähm da die die
Verantwortungen auch ziehen also die die
Klimakrise ist ja unfassbar ungerecht
wir können uns also ich weiß nicht wie
es Ihnen geht bei mir schließt sich da
der Magen zu wenn also es geht Menschen
die die stoßen einfach deutlich mehr CO2
aus das andere und die ist am meisten am
härtesten treffen wir sind aber die
armen so wenn die Hitze immer weiter
steigt dann trifft das eben den
Straßenbauer und dann trifft es die
dachdeckerinnen und nicht den Firmenchef
in seinem klimatisierten Büro und
dergleichen finden sich immer mehr
Beispiele und am Ende ist es aber auch
so wenn ich mir denke okay wenn wir an
diesen Punkt kommen dass dass die dass
das Lebensmittel immer und immer teurer
werden dann dann hilft es mir auch
irgendwie nicht wenn ich mich da jetzt
noch ein paar Jahre länger raus kaufen
kann weil am Ende trifft uns diese Krise
halt gesamtgesellschaftlich und dann
müssen wir eben auch
gesamtgesellschaftlich eine Lösung
finden ich würde gerne noch ein zwei
Fragen aus dem Chat beantwortet bekommen
da geht einer an Sie Herr Backhaus ähm
Herr Backhaus wo und wie kommen sie
ihrer Verantwortung für die
nachfolgenden Generationen und unser
Umwelt nach vielleicht auf die Schnelle
dann haben die Sinnflut ich habe keine
Kinder
gut nächste Frage an Sie aber Chaos wenn
alle so leben würden wie Sie Herr
Backhaus auch in den ärmeren Ländern
dann könnten wir einpacken dann wird es
zu heiß in den ärmeren Ländern sie
werden flüchten müssen was sagen sie
dazu
ähm also ich glaube ich habe das ja
schon gesagt wenn man Witz definitiv und
wir müssen uns darüber Gedanken machen
wie wir damit umgehen auf jeden Fall
wir haben noch eine Frage an Herrn back
an Herrn Schlaf Verzeihung warum klebt
euch nicht vor das Kanzleramt
da waren wir auch also wir führen
verschiedenste Formen des Protestes
durch
und ich wiederhole das gerne was ich
vorhin auch schon mal gesagt habe dass
diese Form des Protestes die empört das
verstehe ich und die empört aber aus
einem Grund weil wir eben darüber immer
wieder an den Punkt kommen dass wir die
Frage uns selbst stellen müssen okay
warum machen Menschen das und dann
kommen wir an den Punkt dass wir sagen
alles klar okay Klima ist es jetzt
wirklich so schlimm wie das gesagt wird
was sagt da eigentlich die Wissenschaft
und was ist eigentlich die Rolle der
Politik und das darüber eben eine
Protestbewegung entsteht nicht alle
Menschen müssen sich auf die Straße
kleben aber alle Menschen müssen
irgendwie aktiv werden müssen sich
vernetzen und Druck ausüben auf die
Bundesregierung damit eben eine Politik
gemacht wird die ihre verfassungspflicht
nachkommt und die unsere
Lebensgrundlagen schützt
salomera schreibt auch an Sie Herr
Backhaus interessant dass Herr Backhaus
der seinen Wohlstand früheren
progressiven Kräften verdankt ist nicht
versteht dass die letzte Generation und
andere auch für ihn kämpfen also damit
meint sie sie profitieren von den
Bemühungen wollen aber dazu nicht
beitragen das ist ziemlich
unwahrscheinlich dass irgendjemand von
uns von diesen Bemühungen Bemühungen
großartig profitiert
weil wenn ich jetzt hier in Hamburg in
die Elbe Spucke dann passiert gar nichts
und wenn wir alle deutschen da in die
Elbe spucken passiert auch nichts also
ich glaube man macht sich zu viele
Hoffnungen dass dadurch dass
irgendjemanden Elektroauto fährt oder
irgendjemand seinen Ladekabel früher aus
der wann zieht oder von mir aus dem
Fahrrad fährt oder sowas ähnliches ist
da gibt es ja genügend Untersuchungen
das dass das in in der großen Klima
Dynamik weltweit eigentlich überhaupt
gar keine Auswirkungen hat und deswegen
würde mich viel mehr interessieren warum
sich nicht irgendwie
in China vor vor die Staatskanzlei klebt
anstatt hier in Deutschland
also ich bin mündiger Bürger in diesem
Land und hier kann ich aktiv sein so und
das ist quasi gesagt dass es ihnen so um
diese Budgets geht und so weiter und das
heißt wenn wir hier über ein kleines
Budget reden warum gehen Sie nicht auf
das große Budget
also zunächst mal hat Deutschland selbst
eine große Verantwortung
unserer CO2-Emissionen pro Kopf sind
höchst sind nach wie vor höher als die
in China ansonsten ja die absoluten sind
höher als ich China was wir aber auch
häufig aus acht lassen bei dieser
Diskussion ist für wen Länder wie China
eigentlich produzieren und die
produzieren eben auch für Deutschland
und da könnten wir auch reingehen mit
einem starken lieferkettengesetz z.B
dass wir sagen Leute wir kaufen euch den
Kram nicht mehr ab wenn nämlich
entsprechend produziert worden ist und
meine Verantwortung ist eben zunächst
mal hier in meinem Land Deutschland
schafft die Ziele auch nicht jedes Land
muss die Ziele schaffen und ähm was ich
mache mit meinem Prozess Protest ist
eben die Bundesregierung an ihre
verfassungspflicht zu erinnern und ja
deswegen mache ich das hier hier ist es
eben für also hier kann ich das machen
weil ich kann nicht einfach mal eben
nach China chatten aber wenn ich das
übersetze dann fordern Sie ja
letztendlich dass die dass die
demokratische Regierung eher zu einer
diktatorischen Regierung wird weil wenn
sie uns Bürger fragen und da gibt es ja
genügend Umfragen
was Menschen tun würden um
Klimawandel aufzuhalten etc pp und da
kommen ja nicht die Antworten die sie
sich wünschen das heißt sie wünschen
sich von der Politik dass sie dem Bürger
irgendwas auf Dock trainieren was er
eigentlich nicht will also ich nehme das
Schlagwort gerne auf das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat gesagt dass
dass die der das dass die
Bundesregierung jetzt Maßnahmen
durchführen muss damit eben die
Maßnahmen die Sie zum Erhalt der
Verfassung zum Erhalt dieser
verfassungspflicht in der Zukunft damit
diese Maßnahmen dann nicht diktatorisch
sein müssen das hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt das
heißt was ich mache hat eine
grunddemokratische Intention und auch
mein Prozess des grunddemokratisch die
Grund also wie gesagt Dinge die für uns
selbstverständlich sind überhaupt erst
durch solche Protestformen erkämpft
worden
ich habe noch eine letzte Frage an Sie
beide vielleicht sie zuerst denn ein
Vorwurf den sie sich wirklich beide
gefallen lassen müssen ist das ja keine
Seite auf die andere zugeht wie soll man
denn so das Klima retten wie will man
denn da zusammenkommen
also wenn Sie mich fragen ist es glaube
ich nicht zielführend mit so einer
sektenähnlichen Struktur überhaupt zu
reden
und Herr schnah was wäre ihr
lösungskonzentrierter Ansatz also ich
denke unser lösungsorientierter Ansatz
ist bekannt dass der gesellschaftsrat
das eben Menschen aus die allen
Schichten der Gesellschaft
zusammenkommen auf Augenhöhe miteinander
sprechen und gemeinsame Lösung finden
ich denke das ist der demokratische
Prozess den wir uns vorstellen können
immerhin Herr Backhaus herrschner haben
sie heute miteinander gesprochen bei uns
dafür danke ich Ihnen schon mal ganz
herzlich und wünsche Ihnen noch eine
gute Zeit tschüss alles Gute
ja wir haben viel gehört das wollen wir
jetzt noch schnell einordnen mit
Professor Felix kreuzig von der TU
Berlin
schönen guten Abend guten Abend
sie haben alles mitbekommen alles gehört
sind sie jetzt Team letzte Generation
Team Julien Backhaus Team weder noch
bestimmt kein Team an ich würde aber
sagen dass Herr Schnarr in zwei
zentralen Punkten auf jeden Fall recht
hat nämlich erstens dass wir vor einer
bedrohlichen Klimakatastrophe stehen
dass wir also alles tun müssen um die
Erwärmung in Grenzen zu halten 1,5 Grad
wird sehr schwer sein aber wir kämpfen
um jedes Zehntel Grad da der schnell
recht und das andere der andere zentrale
Aussage ist es die Politik die handeln
muss es geht um den politischen Willen
die Instrumente zu ergreifen denn die
Technologien die gibt es tatsächlich um
den klimaschutztag voranzubringen und
die Technologien sind mittlerweile auch
so gut dass der Klimaschutz
kostengünstig ist denn PV die
Photovoltaik also Elektroautos
wärmepumpen sind mittlerweile die
günstigsten Technologien bzw Elektroauto
wird das ein paar Jahren sein
Ricardo schreibt der individuelle CO2
Fußabdruck ist ein messbarer Wert der
nicht lügt und der ist bei Wohlhaben
drin Menschen im Durchschnitt einfach
größer da gibt's nichts zu
interpretieren also dass die Reichen das
Klima unverhältnismäßig stärker belasten
als andere das belegen die Zahlen aber
werden sie denn auch in der Lage allein
das Klima zu retten
alleine werden die Reichen das Klima
Problem nicht lösen können
es die Klimapolitik muss auch im partial
sein das heißt alle gleich behandeln
denn nur dadurch gibt es auch das
gesellschaftliche Vertrauen in die
Klimapolitik das ist also wichtig das
gesagt stimmt natürlich dass die Reichen
mehr finanzielle Möglichkeiten haben in
den Klimaschutz zu investieren sie macht
mehr mentale Kapazität als der
autonomalverbraucher der im täglichen
durcheinander sich um die Miete kümmern
muss und so weiter also hier haben die
reich natürlich mehr Verantwortung auch
im Handeln und würden Sie sagen die
Regierung unternimmt genug um die
Milliarden der reichen eben für den
Klimaschutz zu mobilisieren
also die Regionen unternimmt nicht
genügend um die Klimaziele zu erreichen
ich glaube das ist erstmal die zentrale
Aussage das muss man jetzt nicht
miteinander vermengen das sind separate
Themen
sie sitzen ja auch in einem Expertenrat
der das Verkehrsministerium berät sind
Gesellschaft und Politik gleichermaßen
bereit und in den Startlöchern das Klima
zu schützen
der Verkehrsbereich ist sehr interessant
auch gerade in diesem Kontext weil die
Emissionen gerade im Verkehrsbereich am
ungleichen verteilt sind das heißt hier
stoßen die Reichen überproportional viel
aus was dich natürlich kristallisiert in
den Privatflugzeugen und vor allen
Dingen auch in den Yachten wo die
Missionen sehr hoch sind gerade im
Transportbereich passiert auch auf
deutscher Ebene zu wenig also hier wenn
die Klimaziele nicht eingehalten und
hier wäre weitere politische Handlungen
notwendig um z.B die Emission auch bei
von Privatflugzeugen zu senken
es gibt eine Frage an Sie von Thomas
bürel wann werden die kippelemente
erreicht und was wären die Konsequenzen
sind die Schäden ihre Parabel es gibt
verschiedene Art von kippelementen die
anstehen und einige könnten schon in den
nächsten Jahren ähm
vorankommen und andere erst später das
heißt es geht nicht um das eine Element
oder das eine das alle auf einmal
auftreten und natürlich ist es bei
diesen kippelementen gerade in der
Antarktis mit dem Abschmelzen der
Eiskappen das Problem dass diese
irreversibel erstmal sind das heißt dass
wir dann über Jahrhundert lang vor einem
Meeresspiegel Anstieg vorstehen egal ob
wir Klimaschutz machen oder nicht
trotzdem lohnt sich der Klimaschutz
natürlich um eben weitere Elemente zu
verhindern
es gibt noch einen Kommentar von
Battlestar 540 leben und leben lassen
jeder soll die Dinge machen die im Spaß
machen so funktioniert's aber auf Dauer
nicht oder
also Klimaschutz eine
Gemeinschaftsaufgabe das heißt den
können wir nur zusammen lösen und dazu
braucht es natürlich politische
Rahmenbedingungen die das ermöglichen
das bedeutet auch also zum Beispiel der
zu zwei Preis ist wichtig dann das
klimager Geld das den Leuten auch
ermöglicht wieder in Klimaschutz was
auszugeben und das bedeutet auch für die
Bundesregierung Infrastrukturen zu
investieren dies also zum Beispiel
Ladesäulen oder Fahrradwege die das
umweltfreundlich im klimafreundliche
Verhalten überhaupt erst ermöglichen und
jetzt sagt Jupiter Zeus die Reichen in
Deutschland bezahlen auch die meisten
steuerern und von Steuern werden die
Klima Kosten reduziert ist das
ausreichend
das ist jetzt nur eine andere Debatte
nämlich die
ungleichheitsverteilungsdebatte da gibt
es auf jeden Fall Meinungen die sagen
das gerade ist nicht da nicht um die
Einkommensteuer geht sondern eben die
Vermögenssteuer und die Erbschaftssteuer
also um den
gesamtreichtum und gar nicht um die
sondern Floß also die Einkommens Effekte
und hier lohnt es sich auf jeden Fall
mehr hin zu gucken dass es aber einen
weiteren Thema
wenn sie es jetzt in der Hand hätten was
würden Sie ab morgen in Deutschland
ändern um das Klima zu retten
also es sind viele Sachen angelegt der
Klimaschutz steht insgesamt gar nicht so
schlecht da was passieren wird dass wir
über das ETS2 werden auch höhere
CO2-Preise in den sektorenverkehr und in
den Wohnungsbereich ankommt dazu braucht
ein Klima Geld es geht jetzt um die
Umsetzung ins Klimagerät dass die
Haushalte auch wieder ähm etwas zur
Verfügung haben und das andere zentrale
Instrument ist der im Verkehrsbereich
sind die Fahrzeuge denn wenn wir weiter
Verbrennermotor SUVs verkaufen dann
stehen wir vor dem Problem dass die
Preise sehr hoch sind dass viele aber an
schon diese Fahrzeuge haben deswegen
geht es jetzt darum die Verkäufe von
dieser Art von Fahrzeugen zu regulieren
ich höre da gibt's noch einige dicke
Bretter zu bauen Herr kreuzig ich danke
Ihnen ganz sehr herzlich für Ihre
Einschätzung schönen Abend noch
ja und damit sagen wir auch Ihnen und
Euch tschüss für heute ZDF heute live
vielen Dank noch und einen schönen Abend
[Musik]